à la place de ce grand costaud qui va
ouvrir ses portes dans les prochaines
semaines il y avait un neuf trous du
golf métropolitain d'anjou une
conversion qui plaît au maire de
l'arrondissement je crois qu'à la fin du
développement économique d'une façon
écologique tout en maintenant l'écologie
et puis faut pas oublier 51 % des
revenus de la ville de montréal provient
du non résidentiel ça prend quand même
des jobs ou sinon le golfe qui borde le
boisé d'anjou voudrait convertir
d'autres terrains ceux qui sont au nord
du parcours et permettre l'installation
d'un centre de distribution selon la
mairesse ces candidats de valérie
plantes qui s'y opposent il ya d'autres
terrains disponibles dans l'est c'est
pas ça qui manque mais on va les
détruire le dernier espace vert vierge
dans ce coin si pour moi ça fait comme
ça on est pas obligé de parler juste
développement économique ou juste
développement durable l'avenir passe par
les deux ans saint denis coderre qui a
signé un pacte de non agression avec
luis miranda et ne présentera pas de
candidat estime que le terrain n'est pas
propice pour un grand parc au massacre
ou des contenus chez un ancien de la
pioline
sa part les bains enfin à fêter car mais
la réalité c'est que si on veut avoir
quelque chose qui a de l'alluré
il faut commencer par connaître le sol
dans lequel tu es à ma connaissance les
taux de contamination ne sont pas
suffisamment élevée pour empêcher que
des gens qui jouent au golf et s'il
préférerait un vaste parc le conseil
régional de l'environnement se
contenterait du statut court même déjà
dans son état actuel
le golf contribuer à la biodiversité
locale à la gestion de la température
locale c'est à dire la lutte contre les
îlots de chaleur urbains
contribue également la gestion des eaux
de pluie du côté de la chambre de
commerce l'accueil est plutôt favorable
ce qu'on le demande une vision parce
qu'on a une occasion extrême
pour tous les résidents de l'est le sort
du golfe pourraient bien être scellé au
lendemain du 7 novembre ici mathieu
prost radio canada montréal